c'est l'heure d'un nouveau let's play
les avis sur arte classe 2 [ __ ] ça
fait trois ans que j'attends le 2 je le
rappelle y aura un épisode qui sera mise
en ligne tous les deux jours c'est un
bonus ce let's play par rapport aux
vidéos que je fais chaque semaine y aura
toujours quatre vidéos normale sur autre
chose car le plein chaque semaine alors
j'avais juge jouer à la démo sur ps4 non
je n'ai regardé aucun trailer aucune
bande annonce pour ne pas être spoilé
avoir un maximum de plaisir
ambiance obscurité posé et pas tamisée
poser ses parties ligne longueur manette
une journaliste d'investigation à la
recherche de réponses concernant le
meurtre d'une femme enceinte dans des
circonstances impossible dans une région
rurale d'arizona vous êtes blake
langmann son mari assistants et
cameramans enregistré tout ce que vous
voyez ni elle ni vous n'êtes des
combattants pour traverser les horreurs
qui vous attendent dans le désert vo
seul choix sont de courir vous cacher ou
mourir [ __ ] est la pression mcad et
elle est comme ça
[Musique]
il arrive
or été dormir la nuit dernière
je crois que c'est que de ruines comment
cette façon c'est de terre de chercher
une sortie du g20 cherche et minéral rdr
avec tiger génial [ __ ] c'est trop bien
comme angle le vieux reportage là ok je
cadre pour un professionnel
[Applaudissements]
qui pourrait faire venir rencontrer on
peut dire qu'on fait prêt jérôme
bergeron n'a été retrouvé ni environ
seules et aux femmes s'y retrouveront de
voter
on a perdu ma terre
tellement j'étais tellement content vit
pas depuis le temps qu'on attendait ça
ça commence direct roulis chute
oh mais c'est le bâtiment dans lequel on
était dans l'intro dans la démo par le
but du jeu sur ps4
ça fait longtemps que ma joie de jeu
d'horreur en plus je suis tous
complètement paniqué
quel est ce casier tout jessica firth
place d'accord ok très bien
ok c'est un souvenir chez sas epsad donc
ça c'est dans le passé à mon avis c'est
une sorte de cauchemar
c'est un cauchemar qu'il est en train de
faire après avoir touché le sol suite au
crash d'hélicoptère à vis un truc du
genre oh [ __ ] ils marchent plus vite
que nous beaucoup trop de pression oh
[ __ ]
et vous qui vouliez un peu de jeu
d'horreur parce que ça vous manquait je
pense car notre dose monga pour huit
années très clairement dessous le design
du jeu il est
cette masse est ok merci je l'avais dit
c'est un cauchemar
c'était sûr il est écrit qu'il était
attaché mais ça montre je peux dire que
mourir avec toi ça va avec
j'espère qu'il n'est pas blessé ok on à
la caméra avec un maximum de batterie je
l'espère merde [ __ ] faut que descendre
faut que je cherchais magot fougasse
féline ya que ça qui compte
ok ou j'existe wye.n d'accord ça marche
en appuyant sur tarn par l'objectif je
peux pas sauter puisque ça mais ça passe
par là [ __ ] je dis ça va être
compliqué mais qu à la la la la la la
mais mais qu'on sent tellement les
années de travail c'est incroyable ok
super je peux descendre plus bas encore
ou ou et par là aulas est le grand saut
là à temps pour accéder une corniche
déplacer ou dans sa direction
ok ça va vous être utile tout ça parce
que mais qu'on va fuir les psychopathes
ouvert nous tuer à maintes reprise
elle sera bien content de sa refaire sa
gauche contrôle hockey fortin faut que
je m'en souvienne mec avec la panique le
stress que j'aille voir que je le fais
pour poursuivre je sais pas si si le
souffle les événements importants
doivent être enregistrées appuyé sur
clément pour les autres caméscopes
l'enregistrement sur automatiquement
bakou savez vous planter correctement le
caméscope chevènement a enregistré
pendant que musquin sûrement jusqu'à ce
que sa cause soit remplie pour
l'enregistrer complètement d'accord
nouvelle mécanique alors
d'accord [ __ ] c'est rigolo et à la fin
va y avoir un montage de tous ces
moments qu'on aura fait vidéo
enregistrée vers des vidéos enregistrées
pour en savoir plus sur les annonces et
les objectifs
ok donc je peux la rejouer elle n'était
pas là et peut-être encore en vie c'est
génial
ils commandent quoi [ __ ] c'est génial
mais que c'est génial ça me plaît déjà
regarde bon alors il n'y a que 10 heures
le pilote salariat pas de corps elle
écrit si elle n'est pas là une [ __ ]
mec s'est fait enlever par les mais
[ __ ] mec là qu'on a vu dans la démo
vision nocturne up f aux mêmes s'agit
quand on vient de retrouver ça c'est
super c'est génial
bon par contre on va faire la technique
en économie de piles mec ça commence
comme ça pas écrasé mais je suis je sais
que tu crois pas m'étaler choc mais oh
[ __ ] ça c'est c'est une touche au rio
la qui se passe ok c'est une touche
horrible parce que ça veut dire qu'à des
moments sera poursuit faudra regarder
derrière comme des décos à j'aime pas du
tout ce que j'avais l'impression bon
continuons s'enfonça olalalala c'est
beau c'est beau c'est fluide et tu
demander quoi on va revivre la démo en
fait la vraie
on va revivre la démo hu dans la maison
est ce que c'est un bon plan je suis
perdue et blessés [ __ ] c'est oui
dommage à l'inversé la démo ça j'ai
craint temps des bruits de pas
l'enseignant [ __ ] ça y est les jeux la
parano commence déjà à quoi tient là à
l'eau je peux ouvrir l'asie joue je vois
quelqu'un ou pas là au mec je me casse
direct je me casse direct quelle idée de
merde faut que je retrouve ma go et et
que je vende à rien faut vite que je
retrouve vous jetez un coup d'oeil plus
ou moins sûr non me dis pas que
sarko je suis content mais pas trop
allez on y va c'est parti oh [ __ ]
oui on pouvait se cacher dans les bidons
c'est ça bon là on va rechercher un
[ __ ] j'suis suppression make me levais
le mille je peux frapper quelqu'un
ok je rentre il ya une note [ __ ] de
merde on n'est pas bien les amis chers
pères notre du bien aimé quand tu ne
gagnes un de ses visions et je suis plus
certaine que jamais que l'ennemi
approche chaque jour ce qui se passe
chez toi étages de plancher de la
jordanie route la musique benhima
traverser pour jouer dans une vision
très bientôt ce qui est bien c'est que
sont pas fous si bien c'est qu'ils sont
vraiment pas fou ça fait plaisir
il est au low de bâtard mec je sais
qu'il ya un mec qui rôde pas loin c'est
évident c'est d'une évidence
considérable et il va un moment donné se
met à nous courir après c'est un portage
projet de passer par la maison bien
évidemment pour il est fier d'appuyer
sur a ok ça va aller ça va aller ça
valait [ __ ] je l'avais oublié celui-là
au shit au shit certaine quand on est
sûrs qu'il va utiliser pour les
verrouiller ou déverrouiller nouvelle
mécanique aussi du coup je crois pas
qu'ils adorent en france ok on m'a même
façon oui par ce petit coin contrôle
ok ralalala le gameplay filmée que c'est
un truc de ouf c'est tout s'enchaîne
parfaitement bien un peu la mire en
reste coi
c'est très très fort avec je crois il ya
des prix je vous jure qu'elle avait
autour de moi j'vous jure calibre autour
de moi c'est horrible horrible
complainte sage femme l'enfant arrive
repartent au couteau l'enfant arrive
sages-femmes de nuit marseillais de
l'intérieur parlait de mes créations de
dieux sauvés par le péché très bien bon
bah on voit l'ambiance 1 on voit
l'ambiance clairement de 2,2 hors classe
2 et elle nous fait à la fois plaisir et
pas du tout plaisir ici [ __ ] pas du
tout plaisir lors l'option alors on y va
en effet recevoir dix afin qu'on puisse
autant pour moi [ __ ] mec
j'étais en panique et que je n'arrive
plus à flécher correctement non
non en train de s'enfoncer mes mecs
c'est le pire truc à faire ramper oh
[ __ ] sa flore le voir plus tard qu'on
peut passer sous des portiques comme ça
pas évident les livres de vie de
l'agneau immolé qu'est ce qui se passe
là bas je connais c'est le lit le livre
de vie du poulet braisé
mais oh là là non l'entend parler quoi
genre il est vachement proche en fait il
est collé oh oui ok ça qu'on fait [ __ ]
les mecs mais elle est juste à côté on
attend de voir hier joint au caire des
bûches qui me retient de ça elle est où
oui la personne qui parlait mec ça me
pète les couilles à un feu qui
quoi quoi quoi quoi déjà les chats mais
non mais mais ce n'est pas possible mais
mais vous mais où sommes-nous là où
sommes nous je sais pas où est l'erreur
mais qu'elle a disparu
c'est une vision c'est une vision
c'était une vision c'était une vision
c'est une vision aux mecs vazimba on va
aller chez toi il ya peut-être magot
magot où es-tu nickel
j'espère que c'est pas ton sens du
bandage voir combien de bardage bois
s'appelait sur table trouver line hockey
yacco j'ai compris que vous dites
incapables double objectif t'inquiète
pas vas-y un jour à l'inrs line
[ __ ] faut que je trouve on pourra
manger du link ensemble sur le chocolat
lindt impute à la blague cajasur qui
nous met bien pendant ce d'esprit
incroyable voyage modulaire est
probablement le dernier
vu l'ambiance qui règne dans ce milieu
toujours titution sommet genre de
situation comme secte à une partie ton
corps qui n'est pas de l'autre côté le
calvez shanty secteur puissant déplacer
certaines certains objets en maintenant
oui ok d'accord je veux j'ai compris le
délire je veux pas trop que ça va me
servir si mais ok ok c'est très bien
fait tout un en fait c'est pas du tout
comme dans la démo c'est la démo c'était
vraiment trop fait sur mesure mais déchu
face à la religion musulmane perdu au
cours des croisades et traille autant
des pharisiens public
ils sont ils sont complètement barré
mais qu'un très clairement on est dans
le village des gens fous voilà passe
plus tôt j'espère là je connais aux
places j'ai très bien que le sol va se
casser et qu'on va tomber nez à nez avec
quelqu'un qu'on avait vraiment pas envie
de voir ça va être mec c'était sûr ou
pas c'était sûr c'était évident fake et
l'on va se retirer par les pieds on va
se retourner ailleurs un mec
mais arrête arrête tu veux que je meurs
ok il prend le temps de répondre quand
même mais c'est pas avec ce style déjà
que tu va convertir quiconque vraiment
eu
bon bref allez on dégage mais fait très
très peur se cacher et je peux me barrer
wemmel et autour quoi [ __ ] mais que ça
sente pas bon ça sent pas bon non c'est
là d'où je viens je sais leur projet
vous pouvez entendre entre les murs à
suivre les bruits avec le microphone de
votre caméscope parce que tu viennes
gros fans puissent trouver assez fort ça
[Applaudissements]
donc il ya un make up ont verrouillé la
porte mais comme s'en est tranquille on
va essayer de gaieté par la junte à me
m'allonger mec
on sait qu'il ya du monde là à temps
alors des verrues sont ok ils sont
maladroites ya personne arago choqué
alors c'est parti
mais là bas et là bas ça son mec qui va
forcément nous repérer un attend on va
tenter de l'allant en mode accroupi dans
les hautes herbes
c'est que ça passera mais qui va
l'opérer c'est sûr ah non c'est bon pour
regarder maintenez contrôle pour vous
cacher dans les plantes à hauteur de
taille on est bien là mais ultra bien
mec je passe en dessous
il ya un autre mec oh il y en a deux
comme à gauche à droite les renards
c'est nous en l'occurrence c'est ça et
toi tu veux tuer du renard [ __ ] de
fouilles de merde il faut concours mais
qu on n'a pas le choix il faut se lever
prendre ces bowles et courir tu es un
athlète
là
[Applaudissements]
y aller il va c'est vrai ok je pensais
maintenant il faut y aller ok on est
caché
on est caché on est dans les hautes
herbes folles et tout droit à mon avis
le mec c'est que le blu-ray musique le
mec roach derrière nous et ça sonne un
maximum de pression comme techno chez le
garagiste
je veux qu la pression d'une manière ou
d'une autre
oh
c'est qu'aux gauchers parce que c'était
bête mais ça m'a sauvé la vie
c'est vrai ça comme si c'était comme si
c'est bizarre mais qu au shit je fais
quoi quand je suis là faut que j'ouvre
ça d'accord d'accord d'accord c'est par
là d'accord d'accord mais en fait c'est
un village ouais c'est ils sont
endoctrinés dans un dans une secte en
fait signe sec
en gros voilà on est dans une petite
secte et c'est super flippant cette
femme non il parle de ma femme faut que
j'aille la sauver l'une faut que
j'allais aux [ __ ] la part la plus
longue du monde à déverrouiller à noël
va mourir devant l art by aux noms
étranges
les allées ou comment ça sauf commenge
açores faut que je déplace à faut que
j'aie passage peux pas je peux pas non
mais ça c'est des cellules en fait tu
pas au bon endroit du tout là par la
caméra y'a rien yann clay ok je dois la
clé c'est bon t'es de la prison faut que
jours une cellule par la regarder ok on
[Musique]
a les clés de la piste je ne tiens pas
deuxième mais comme ça là dedans non
c'est bon ok j'ai un bandage ça va ce
fight faut que la sauvette ok on va
montrer ses bons bloqué mais non mais
non je me cachais dans les armoires sas
est très mauvaise il va y avoir un mec
[ __ ] les mecs regarder on les voit ils
sont juste là haut
maintenant tout est fermé mais comme par
hasard
les minimes théo lindt hockey au corps
ok ok ça l'est tout on est bien or ça
fait trop plaisir d'amour n'importe où
mais restons pas ici oh [ __ ] l'air
tellement terrorisée mec
vas-y je te souviens amène moi il va
nous arriver un truc salle c'est évident
qu'est ce qu'il ya non
délire de possession merde non non elle
est possédée mais qu elle va se
retourner ce sera une une meuf
je dois m'arrêter j'ai juste besoin
mon dieu portel de medellin
qu'est ce qui se passe ici je croyais
que tu étais mort quand tu tombes et je
croyais qu'on était tous nos ballons
tout va bien je suis là on va sortir ici
ok
fait je vais pas en parler
les jetons prime les trousses la
question mais ils ont fait quoi quand on
fait quoi pourquoi tu es comme ça mais
qui lui ont mis un démon dans le corps
c'est sûr [ __ ] on marche à deux à
l'heure ok le bouton halles qui sert à
voir ce qui se passe derrière d'accord
va pouvoir courir quand même pour le
bien de cet enfant 1
ils vont nous rattraper oh non allez
vous en nous allons être est tout
c'est sûr devant dieu que le premier kim
tout de suite tu laves lisieux je
l'entends
allez
c'est quoi ça sert et sorte de mousse
j'ai regardé mon style est vraiment
possible
c'est un choix partagé cette femme heck
qu'est ce truc qui me tient la rend il
ya des brindilles dans son grade manga
d'allumer un peu avec sa tête pas comme
je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est dégueulasse
oui mon petit on est raynaud je pense
non non vraiment pas j'insiste en fin de
deuxième rendez vous c'est un nom c'est
un grand nom up
ok j'ai la caméra et je vais devoir
chasser m'a en fait je vais devoir
chercher ma femme pendant tout le jeu
cesa elle est plus la tâche est sonné et
elle est plus là y'a plus personne à
part ce mec s'est fait casser le cou les
critiques sont appelés line mr oui y'a
pas que la secte je les chrétiens
ouais ouais ouais et un truc très très
malsain à qu'on découvrira dans le
prochain épisode
eh ben les avis afin de le première
épisode de ce nouveau l'expansion et les
deux ne s'étaient pas aller mais en
masse ça vous a plu ça me fait super
plaisir et ben mecque pour un premier
épisode je suis cookies je suis ravie je
m'attendais n'y a moins bien y'a mieux
c'est parfait alors se trouve jeudi pour
le prochain épisode tous les deux jours
comme j'ai dit au début de la vidéo
portez vous bien sûr tout le monde ça
nous a tendu un peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]